Elita battle angel is directed by Robert
Rodriguez and produced by James Cameron
who has had the rights for this forever
I remember back in the day reading about
what he might want to do with this
project getting very excited about it
for years and then eventually I just
lost all hoping and ever being made I've
always loved yokutoku Sheroes manga I
think it's brilliant really influential
stuff check it out sometime if you
haven't it's readily available in just
about every major bookstore and this
film tells the story of Aleta a cyborg
found in a scrap heap by Christoph
Waltz's character doctor II do he's
known for repairing damage to cybernetic
limbs but in this case he completely
reconstructs her body and when she comes
back to life she has no memory of her
past self but she is able to do
incredible things and we get to watch
her journey as she discovers who she is
for anime fans we live in a very
exciting time not only is it readily
available to us at our fingertips but
anime adaptations are happening in the
United States we've had the ghost in the
shell' film this year we have the
Pokemon detective film and now we have
Aleta battle angel people are noticing
just how much of a market there is for
this and gratefully people are noticing
who actually care this is by no means a
flawless movie it certainly has a lot of
narrative issues and it has some pacing
problems some characterizations that
didn't really work for me some
relationships that didn't really work
for me but it's clear watching the film
as someone who loves the manga and who
really loves this character that
Rodriquez and Cameron really gave a shit
they tried super fucking hard to make a
damn good Elita movie the world is
gorgeous the effects are spectacular
they're some of the best I've seen the
motor ball sequences which in this film
as in the manga it's the sporting events
where people have this metal ball and
they're basically going around a
racetrack and it's very violent and
people can get hurt and killed and those
sequences aren't seen they're so
thrilling and so well done that just
those scenes alone I feel like they're
gonna please a lot of fans of the manga
there's narrative things that have been
changed
nothing super drastic the core aspects
of the manga and what it's about and the
characters in it are translated here to
this film
beautifully this really feels like
elitist world on the big screen and and
the things within it some of the more
subtle nuances of the manga about the
way society views each other the higher
society and then people who are on the
lower part of the world where they want
to go to zalem so badly where everything
is kind of like Elysium you know we're
like everything up there just seems like
this otherworldly heaven that they can't
even comprehend those themes are
retained here pretty well although
sometimes the film does fall back to
action and wanting to be very action
heavy with tons of fights it's not as
cerebral as girls in the show or as
ponderous but it's a lot more action
heavy it doesn't have as much to say
about the human condition as ghost in
the shell' did but this movie is a lot
more concerned with entertaining you I
was able to see the film in IMAX 3d for
the screening and during certain
sequences the aspect ratio expands and
you get a better view of the action
sequences and similar to James Cameron's
Avatar I would recommend seeing this
film in 3d if you get a chance because I
think it added quite a bit to it and I'm
not really a purveyor of 3d I don't
really care that much about it but in
this case I think it added a lot there's
a central romance in the film that came
off a bit cheesy and a little
melodramatic and it didn't really work
for me all the time I didn't really
believe it necessarily as far as the
villains as well there's something
that's used in the movie where the main
bad guy is Nova who's up on zalem and
he's controlling people and speaking
through them in a way and so you never
really get the sense that he's all that
involved he's kind of like the emperor
you know like you've heard about him but
you don't really get to see that much of
him until Return of the Jedi and then
you're like okay I see how he's had his
hands and all these things and so some
of the confrontations in the film
between good and evil felt a little
one-dimensional because I didn't really
feel the villain as a presence because
this movie definitely wants to make
other films in the franchise which for
some I'm sure will be a problem when you
see one and then it's setting up another
one and you feel like you didn't get
what you wanted
some people are gonna be annoyed by that
and I totally understand that at the
same time I think your enjoyment of this
film is going to heavily rely on how
much you like anime or manga because
this film is unapologetically
in your fucking face about being
anime which is one of the reasons I
loved aspects of the film I've wanted to
see films like this for a long time and
I'm excited that we're living in a time
where we're getting stuff like this and
for people who aren't as well-versed
though in anime or manga you're going to
see a lot of things that don't really
make sense that maybe don't narratively
feel like the rest of the bunch this
movie has no qualms with being exactly
what it's trying to be and for some
people that's gonna be a major problem
it's also kind of helpful if you know
something about the manga because then
at least you feel like you have some
attachment you understand the themes
because a lot of my friends who saw it
with me at the screening they went in
and they had a certain expectation and
the film didn't give them that I didn't
have that expectation because I already
had a really well versed knowledge of
what the manga was about and I knew what
the story was about and I've spoken out
against this in the past I've said like
look you can't judge a movie and say
it's better just because you like the
source material that's not fair I still
feel that way I'm just saying that I
might be a little more biased than some
critics in this regard because I love
the manga and I saw so many aspects of
it faithfully translated to the big
screen and so I'm gonna give certain
things that pass maybe that some critics
don't that could be a flaw on my part
with this review and I'm just being
totally real with you guys but you know
that's part of talking about movies is
you have to be honest I fucking love the
manga and aspects of this movie really
did a great job of that
Rose Salazar is fantastic as Aleta and
the special effects I really cannot talk
enough about them Christoph Waltz was
good as II do Jennifer Connelly was
underutilized in her role it didn't feel
like her character had that much to her
they tried to add some things to make
her have more depth and she was fine in
the movie it just felt like her
character wasn't as much of a presence
as the film was hoping she was Mahalo
Ali same his character is often the
puppet of Nova and so in that way it's
hard to really comprehend what side he's
on he obviously has evil goals but then
you also feel bad for him because he's
kind of a victim of mistreatment from
Nova but still I think this is a film
that's much better than
critics are saying it is I think that
it's a movie that technically does so
much for the filmmaking world and it's
really hard if you are an artist to look
at this film and not be impressed with
the amount of work that went into it and
just how insanely beautiful everything
is and if someone who has wanted to see
this film for a long time I didn't leave
disappointed and I would like to see
more I'm gonna give a Lita
battle angel ABI guys thank you so much
as always for watching look forward to
more reviews very soon my wife and I are
gonna see the new How to Train Your
Dragon tomorrow so hopefully I'll have a
review for that this weekend guys thank
you very much as always and if you like
this you can click right here and get
stuck mine eyes
[Music]